destiny has all the things a child could
ask for and perhaps it's Destiny's fate
that she and her brother Mills find
themselves in Europe on the island of
Cyprus here they have a room of their
own full of stuffed toys but their
father tag Bashir had to build all of
this himself he's originally from Sudan
he's been stranded on Cyprus for 17
years they didn't give me anything to
help me to do this house they don't like
it they don't want it because they want
me to move from here and somewhere else
but I don't have nowhere to go
so I have to make myself little bit
comfortable just to survive fun to leave
they are the British Army and their
military base on Cyprus it's a relic of
the colonial era when the island was
still administered by Britain back then
officers and their families lived in
these houses today the children of
refugees from Sudan and from the Kurdish
territories in Syria and Iraq play here
17 years ago their parents were
shipwrecked off the coast near the
British base we had problems with the
boat the engine is stopped and then the
boat has a hole in the middle of it and
then the water stopped getting inside
the boat and the boat stopped throwing
slowly slowly by that means we have
scenes like okay five or ten kilo meter
in front of us it was like a land day
that was October 1998 74 people were on
the boat manned by smugglers hours later
they finally reached land tagged Bashir
was one of the first to scale the cliffs
I've seen one of the soldier was walking
and I was run I ran to him and I asked
him where we are
told him who are you and where you come
from I told him the story that's we came
with the boat and the boat is down there
and the boats carrying people down there
he told me where I told him just down of
the
Mountain there the see told me okay you
are safe it's a British base and lucky
thing that we were thinking that we have
been saved and we gonna start on your
life his and the others new life on
Cyprus was safe but it was also the end
of their dream of travelling onwards in
Europe Doris policarpo has been
following the fate of these refugees for
years the Cypriot helps however he can
but so far no political compromise has
been reached the British they don't want
to give a solution because they are
afraid that this will become and and and
and and encourage other people to use
this as a way to enter UK the Cypriot
authorities they don't want to give a
solution because they consider it that
is a problem of the British so the
British has to find a solution for this
the 15 refugee families living on the
former base are on British territory but
the British government won't let them
move to the UK it would like to deport
them to the Greek Cypriot part of Cyprus
but the refugees see no future for
themselves in Cyprus so they're staying
put Doros Polycarp who has been
assisting Mustafa Seamus for years the
Syrian curd is depressed and has lost
all hope I like to die not stay here me
and my children I wish I died before 18
years and I don't have children much
better you know is make my life more
than there in Syria Britain pays him and
the other refugee families trapped here
500 euros a month it's not enough to
live on because they also have to pay
for electricity water and rent and they
have no right to a work permit or a
standard residency permit he stateless
person from Syria his children are
stateless as well they are born in this
country they are now to have 14 years
other children they are even older and
they don't have as a citizenship
Tagg Beshear doesn't want to think about
things like that
on the rare occasions he destiny and
Mills get to visit a playground outside
the base penny Sadler a British woman
who's cared for the refugees at the base
for years teaches the children English
once a week they seem to be have been
left out in the cold
you know while all this is going on they
would maybe be better off having come
over now be free to go where they want
to Germany to the European countries but
unfortunately 17 years ago this has
happened
Mills and his sister know little about
their father's big dream of making it to
London one day their travels are pretty
much limited to trips to this playground
in a neighboring Greek Cypriot village
before they return to the enclosed
compound they call home
you